cela faisait quelques années qu'on
n'avait pas vu un tel plateau sur un
sprint locale aymeric priam couloir 4
champion de france junior sur 100 m luc
dayan au couloir 5 championne d'europe
espoirs sur 400 m haies mais aussi un
certain loïc hélène au couloir 3 figure
montante de cette nouvelle génération de
sprinteurs sur un départ explosif le
guen prend les commandes de cette finale
du 60 m
malgré la concurrence à ses trousses le
sociétaire du smic de ducos s'impose
avec un chrono spectaculaire de 6
secondes 72 c'est une question d'honneur
avant tout un jeu qu'on s'est figé au
fond on a fini quasiment côte à côte
avec et wiki à michal aussi km cette
année il est beau et bon ben c'est une
question d'honneur et ce sera une finale
des gueux l'album finale du chez les
filles aussi le suspense était au rendez
vous sur la ligne de départ de 60 m
véronique marie josèphe au couloir 6
l'eau à valence au couloir 7 2 filles
tueur brillé lors de leur série mais sur
cette finale c'est laetitia caraman de
l'ue est robert qui s'impose en 7
secondes 56 une performance
encourageante pour la suite de sa saison
les captages et j'ai pu l'âge
malheureusement mais je sais que pour le
captage aurait pu faire ma perf mais est
ce que ce sera aussi à défaut de
réaliser des temps records ou
d'accrocher des minima le 10 veillant
champion d'europe espoirs sur 400 m
haies a souhaité participer à ce
championnat d'hivernage pour travailler
sa vitesse pour moi les hivernages c'est
plus une préparation c'est surtout pour
travailler la vitesse pour se faire
plaisir et retrouver le goût de la
compétition
et puis après repartir sur une bonne
base de travail pour la saison estivale
amenant nos sprinteurs le court au
rendez vous le mois prochain pour le
premier tour de sélection des carifta
pour espérer décrocher leur sésame pour
la compétition phare de l'athlétisme
caribéen